parce que nos villes se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cet
ultime numéro d' équilibre de la saison
une émission spéciale intégralement
consacrée au solar decathlon 2014 de
versailles un solar où nous partons tout
de suite pour vous présenter la
compétition internationale deux
prototypes de maisons solaires qui a été
inaugurée le 27 juin dernier
une ville champignon est apparu sur le
site des matelots à versailles
le 27 juin le solar decathlon 2014 était
inaugurée après on sûr de montage
intense où les équipes composées
d'étudiants architectes et ingénieurs
ont travaillé jour et nuit chantier on a
commencé lundi dernier c'est déjà
cinquième jour il me semble
10 on est sur un système de 3,8 en trois
équipes en tournoi fut du matin et un
accent d'alice un peu difficile pour la
nuit ce qui fait moins on chose qu'ils
ont du mal à dormir
et c'est pas prendre de retard puisque
tout est calé hier par deux ans de
préparation ont été nécessaires pour
concevoir ses prototypes de maisons
fonctionnant à l'énergie solaire
les projets présentés en novembre 2013 à
paris sous forme de maquette prennent
donc aujourd'hui taille réelle
pour l'occasion une cérémonie était
organisée en présence de toutes les
équipes en compétition présente pour
l'événement sylvia pinel ministre du
logement n'a pas caché sa satisfaction
c'est très fiers d'accueillir le solar
decathlon europe 2014 est très fière
aussi d'avoir sur notre territoire des
jeunes qui porte justement cette
ambition cette envie et un immense
talent dès le 30 juin les équipes
recevaient une note par jour et par
catégorie innovation architecture ou
efficacité énergétique seront évalués
jusqu'au 12 juillet par le jury composé
d'experts
une équipe française a dès le premier
jour retenu toute l'attention sur ce
solar decathlon 2014
il s'agit des montées et de leurs
projets philéas nous vous offrons une
visite guidée de leur maison
réintroduire l'agriculture dans nos
habitations urbaines c'est le défi fou
que s'est lancé l'équipe française du
projet philéas il y à un peu plus d'un
an ses étudiants en architecture et
ingénierie décide de se lancer dans la
réhabilitation d'un ancien bâtiment
industriel à nantes appelé cap 44 leur
idée faire de cet édifice datant de 1895
un modèle d'efficacité énergétique et
d'y introduire sous une verrière à son
sommet des cultures de fruits et de
légumes leur prototype de maison solaire
et donc une reproduction écologique à
échelle réduite de ce fameux cap 44 et
le résultat est remarquée on voit
beaucoup d'originalité moi j'ai beaucoup
aimé le projet nantais
c'est la réactivation de l'urbanisme de
l'activité du maraîcher dans une dans
des zones qui ont connu une activité
industrielle d'un autre temps je trouve
ça vraiment génial et je pense qu'il est
bien placé peut-être qu'il saura dans la
short list en fin de parcours
outre la verrière et ses cultures qui
seront exploités par un maraîcher bio
des panneaux solaires laissant passer la
lumière du jour sont installés sur le
toit
l'eau de pluie est également récupérée
filtrer et stockées dans des cuves pour
alimenter les plantations excellent
projet sur le papier la maison solaire
philéas aujourd'hui devenu réalité
satisfait en tout cas pleinement ses
concepteurs c'est exactement ce qu'on
voulait on voulait un prototype de cette
envergure là avec une scénographie assez
chaude
on voulait ramener quelque chose de
vivant des nantais on est super fiers
d'avoir réussi à faire coïncider la
vraie construction avec le plan on a
quand même pas mal de retours positifs
dans le sens où enfin tout le monde
trouve ça énorme ce qu'on a fait nous on
est on est très fier de ce qu'on a fait
les gens nous font savoir que que
c'était pas évident qu'on a réussi un
gros challenge et et que tout le monde
est fier de nous tous ceux qui nous ont
suivis sont fiers de nous deux semaines
de compétition et dix critères de
notation attendent maintenant les
français plaçait d'entrée comme sérieux
challenger à la victoire finale le
projet philéas a pris ses marques sur ce
solar decathlon le samedi 5 juillet
greenpeace était sur le solar decathlon
l'occasion pour les visiteurs de
découvrir un stand sur la transition
énergétique
reportage greenpeace au solar decathlon
de versailles
la célèbre organisation écologique
tenait lors de ce deuxième week-end de
compétition instant de transition
énergétique au milieu des prototypes de
maisons solaires des maisons solaires
qui font partie intégrante des solutions
environnementales de demain de plus
moins coûteuse que le nucléaire
contrairement aux idées reçues
si on compte dans le coût du nucléaire
le coût réel du démantèlement des
centrales le coût des assurances et
surtout le coût de la gestion des
déchets pendant des siècles voire des
milliers d'années à sont là dès
aujourd'hui il est bien évident que le
coût de l'énergie nucléaire
est infiniment plus importante que celui
des énergies renouvelables sauf que
malheureusement ce coup là ne figure pas
aujourd'hui dans le coût du
kilowattheure et beaucoup de français
continuent de croire que le coût du
nucléaire est plus bas que les énergies
renouvelables ce qui est évidemment faux
vidéo explicative ateliers jeux pour les
jeunes ou échanges autour de différents
thèmes de campagne de greenpeace le
stand permettait au public de s'informer
tout en proposant une pause lors de la
visite du solar forfait petite pause et
pour bages et me cite les maisons et ça
permet dé changer un peu les idées les
stratégies sont pour moi ils sont
clairement il faut quand on réduit les
consommations de 60 60 disposons de tout
ce qu'on peut on se rend compte que les
gens y font ils font ils font tout pour
les bien-être personnel mais très peu
pour l'avenir et ça ça ça démonte des
visions et des stratégies revêt plus à
long terme d'ici à 2030 la france a pour
objectif de produire 32 % de
renouvelables dans son mix énergétique
selon greenpeace en leaders européens
les français auraient dû pousser la
production à 45%
le 12 juillet marquait la clôture de ce
solar decathlon 2014
une cérémonie en présence des 20 équipes
révéler à tous le grand vainqueur de
cette édition
si l'italie l'emportent les français de
philéas se classe deuxième résumé de ce
dernier jour du solar 12 juillet jour de
résultats finaux pour le solar decathlon
de versailles mais avant la révélation
du nom de l'équipe gagnante plusieurs
prix spéciaux ont été remis
si les néerlandais s'empare du prix
développement durable et les mexicains
du prix ingénierie et construction
ce sont les nantais et leurs projets
philéas qui remporte le prix de
l'efficacité énergétique
un prix qui récompense un tueur labeur
pour nous ça représente énormément fin
on est on est assez fier de ce prix là
parce que ça signifie qu'on est autonome
en énergie que ce qu'on propose c'est
viable et que comme les meilleurs des
coups là dessus
ça fait plus d'un an qu'on travaille sur
le projet on est plus d'une centaine
d'étudiants avoir participé dessus ça a
été dur parfois mais au final là on
arrive à un résultat qui est génial
c'est une expérience incroyable
le soir une grande cérémonie clôturer la
compétition on allait enfin savoir qui
allait être l'équipe victorieuse de ce
solar decathlon 2014
c'est donc le prototype italien rome
fort dans city et son projet de
réhabilitation des villes antiques grâce
à la construction d'éco quartier qui
l'emportent
l'équipe philéas annoncé parmi les
favoris dès le début de la compétition
se classe finalement deuxième
un excellent résultat au vu du niveau
proposé sur ce saut là qu'on était
quatre niveaux
j'en attendais pas
il faudra désormais attendre deux ans
avant le prochain solar decathlon sur le
territoire européen
le cycle des matelots de versailles et
lieux utilisés pour la compétition cette
année accueillir et lui prochainement
des biennales des célèbres jardins de
son château
c'est la fin de ce numéro d'équilibré
merci à tous de l'avoir suivi pas
d'agenda environnemental ce mois ci j'en
profite donc pour remercier
chaleureusement toute l'équipe qui tout
au long de l'année a fait un travail
formidable sur votre rendez-vous
écologique plus particulièrement elodie
jonathan patrick maxime charlelie et
bien sûr pascal josèphe le monteur de
cette émission
c'était une dernière pour moi aussi je
tenais à vous remercier de votre
fidélité
je vous souhaite bon vent à tous et même
si c'est la dernière ce n'est pas une
raison pour l'oublier
la terre est notre mère respectant la
salut